vamos a ver una consecuencia de la
fórmula que vimos en vídeos pasados de
campo magnético lo que nos deja la
fórmula es que la fuerza que ejerce un
campo magnético sobre una carga en
movimiento es igual a la magnitud de la
carga multiplicada con el producto cruz
de la velocidad con el campo magnético
bueno vamos a jugar con esta fórmula
utilizando que la velocidad está dada
por distancias sobre tiempo o sea por el
vector distancia entre el tiempo vale
entonces vamos a poner esta expresión
aquí a ver qué nos queda nos quedaría
que la fuerza es igual a la carga
multiplicada por hilo voy a escribir así
mira como 1 entre el tiempo por la
distancia y eso producto cruz con el
campo magnético
muy bien ahora este 1 / t es una
cantidad de escalar o sea puede salir
sin problemas de este producto cruz
porque no es vector el tiempo tiene sus
unidades pero no tiene dirección
entonces la podemos poner así podemos
poner que la fuerza es igual a la carga
dividida entre el tiempo multiplicada
por el producto cruz de de la distancia
con el campo magnético muy bien pero ve
que es esto de acá a que nos recuerda
carga entre tiempo o sea que son cool
oms entre segundos pues eso justo son
anvers esto de aquí es corriente eso
está re bueno vamos a reescribir lo
vamos a reescribir este curso brete como
corriente multiplicada por y aquí lo
dejamos igual vale la distancia producto
cruz con el campo magnético excelente
ahorita vamos a utilizar esa fórmula
nada más déjame hacer dos aclaraciones
una es que está el en minúscula a veces
la puedes ver como l mayúscula porque es
porque es un vector entonces a la gente
le gusta ponerle mayúsculas pero bueno
aquí
con l minúscula lo vamos a dejar así y
otra declaración es que está en realidad
no es una fórmula nueva que la fuerza
sea esto pues no sé así se ve diferente
pero nada más la obtuvimos a partir de
la fórmula que ya teníamos
así pues realmente no te la tienes que
memorizar solo tienes que aprenderte la
de acá arriba y acordarte de cómo la
puedes deducir van bueno entonces para
lo que vamos a utilizar esta fórmula es
para ver el efecto que tiene un campo
magnético en un alambre por el cual pues
va pasando cierta corriente déjame
reescribir la fórmula y para para
interpretarla la voy a poner en color
verde para que te la prendas en muchos
colores entonces nos dice nos dice que
la fuerza que ejerce un campo magnético
en un alambre por el cual está pues
pasando una cierta corriente es igual a
iu
la corriente que puede ser positiva o
negativa bueno no sea la corriente por
sí misma siempre es positiva pero eso de
más o menos tiene que ver con la
dirección ahorita no me voy a meter
mucho con eso cuando veamos el ejemplo
va a ser un poco más claro pero bueno es
igual a la corriente multiplicada por el
producto cruz de la longitud del alambre
va el cacho del alambre que nos interesa
con el campo magnético va entonces esto
de aquí es la fórmula en términos de de
la fuerza que ejerce un campo magnético
en un cachito de alambre por el cual
pasa una corriente bueno vamos a ver un
ejemplo supongamos que tenemos un campo
magnético y ya hablamos de campos
magnéticos que van de la pantalla hacia
ti los mismos en el vídeo pasado así que
ahora vamos a cambiar un poco y vamos a
pensar en un campo magnético que va
desde ti hacia la pantalla vale entonces
vamos a pintarlo así como un asta
chiquitas bueno así se pinta y se pinta
así porque si si tú disparas una flecha
nada más verías la cola de la flecha
entonces imagínate que tú disparas una
flecha y entonces hacia allá
para el campo magnético bueno por esta
razón también el campo que va hacia ti
se ve como un circulito con un puntito
porque la flecha ahora va apuntando se
apuntando hacia ti pero bueno entonces
tenemos que este campo va hacia adentro
hacia la pantalla ok entonces aquí
tenemos el ibi estévez que sería el
campo magnético y vamos a pensar que la
magnitud del campo es de un tesla vale
un tesla
ok ahora sí vamos a pintar un alambre
pensemos que un alambre está en la
pantalla en el plano de la pantalla y
que atraviesa este campo magnético más o
menos así va ahí tenemos un cachito de
alambre y está en el plano de la
pantalla bueno voy a dar un poco más de
información además tenemos que saber qué
corriente fluye por el alambre vamos a
pensar que la corriente va pues así
hacia allá pero deja lo pintó así más
bien la corriente va hacia allá va y que
es una corriente de 5 amperes
y finalmente pensemos que nada más nos
interesa una sección del cable que mide
dos metros va que mide dos metros si es
importante la longitud o la sección del
cable que nos interesa porque si tenemos
más cable entonces va a haber más cargas
pasando por esta sección y por lo tanto
la fuerza que actúa sobre ese alambre va
a ser mayor sobre esa sección va a ser
mayor entonces ahorita es de 2 metros
bueno entonces la pregunta es cuál es la
fuerza que el campo magnético ejerce en
esta sección del alambre bueno pues ya
tenemos todo para utilizar la fórmula
vamos a ver qué nos dice lo que nos dice
es que la fuerza es igual a y que es la
corriente que tenemos aquí son 5 amperes
y van hacia ese lado multiplicada por el
amir aquí l tiene una flechita
necesitamos una dirección para pues para
esta longitud bueno podemos pensar la
que va se halla o que va hacia allá y
podemos ponerle un signo distinto
ahorita vamos a pensar que va hacia allá
o sea que es que es la dirección en la
cual van las cargas positivas esto
coincide con lo que platicábamos de
campos magnéticos del mono polo norte
verdad que se movía hacia allá entonces
bueno es bueno pensar lo que estamos
yendo hacia allá va que vamos hacia
dónde vamos hacia dónde va la carga
positiva si queremos pensar en el mundo
real y tenemos electrones cuando los
electrones no es tanto pensar en el
mundo real porque son más un concepto
que una cosa pero bueno si fueran
electrones sería una carga negativa iría
para el otro lado
pero bueno ahorita esto no nos interesa
nos interesa que estamos recorriendo
hacia allá
en esta dirección vale entonces ahora sí
ya con una dirección y una longitud
tenemos la distancia bueno aquí tenemos
la distancia que estamos recorriendo que
va hacia allá muy bien entonces ya
tenemos casi todo vamos a ver que nos
quedarían las cuentas vamos a empezar
con la magnitud vale bueno déjame déjame
escribir esto en términos de que es el
producto cruz porque eso va a ayudarnos
entonces nos quedaría y por la magnitud
de l por la magnitud de b por el seno de
entre estos dos le voy a poner teta y
eso tenemos que multiplicarlo por un
vector unitario
bueno qué es esto estos simplemente en
la fórmula del producto cruz hay que
multiplicar las magnitudes por el seno
del ángulo esto de acá estoy acá sería
la magnitud de la fuerza bueno también
hay que considerar esta idea acá
entonces mejor déjame déjame borrarla
pero bueno esto ya que es la magnitud
del producto cruz y para saber la
dirección tenemos que multiplicar por un
vector unitario que después de
terminaremos con la regla de la mano
derecha entonces pues vamos por partes
empecemos con la magnitud a mira puedo
agarrar hasta acá y entonces ahora sí
sería la magnitud de la fuerza entonces
empezamos con la magnitud de la fuerza
esto lo podemos conocer fácilmente va
entonces que nos quedaría nos quedaría
que la magnitud de la fuerza es igual a
la corriente que la tenemos son 5
amperes vamos le voy a poner el 5 bueno
15 amperes multiplicado por la magnitud
de la distancia o sea por la longitud
que son dos metros dos metros quizás
aquí debería ponerle sus flechitas
multiplicado por la magnitud del campo
del campo magnético que es un tesla
multiplicado por el seno del ángulo
entre entre esta distancia que estamos
recorriendo y el campo magnético pero
otra vez volvemos a lo mismo del vídeo
pasado el campo está atravesando la
pantalla y este alambre está en la
pantalla entonces el alambre con el
campo forman un ángulo de 90 grados y
por lo tanto estoy acá es igual a un
seno de 90 grados o de pi medios es
igual a
nos fijamos que todo esté en el sistema
internacional amperios metros
tesla y muy bien entonces la magnitud
sería 5 por 210 y estamos en sistema
internacional entonces son newtons ok
con eso terminamos con la magnitud pero
ahora nos falta ver pues hacia dónde
está yendo esta fuerza verdad cómo le
hacemos para saber la para para saber
pues tenemos que ver hacia dónde va este
vector unitario y eso lo determinamos
con la regla de la mano derecha vamos a
hacer la vamos a tomar aquí está en este
color de acá entonces cómo funciona esto
pues igualito a cómo funcionaba antes
hacia allá está yendo cada una de las
cargas entonces hacia allá tiene que
apuntar nuestro dedo índice verdad es el
primer término en el producto cruz
déjame dibujar por aquí también muñeca
esta de aquí tiene que ser una mano
derecha entonces quedaría algo de este
estilo por aquí viene el índice en
dirección de dl vale
y el segundo término el campo magnético
está apuntando hacia adentro entonces
por aquí quedaría mi dedo medio va bueno
que está apuntando hacia adentro de aquí
no se puede ver más bien debería de
pintarlo como así digo me tienes que
creer que está apuntando hacia adentro
le puedo poner una tacita y mis otros
dedos se hacen por aquí y alguna otra
cosa va entonces por aquí va mi mano
algo así y luego qué sucede con mi
pulgar pues mi pulgar mi pulgar apunta
hacia allá
hacia esa dirección va entonces cómo
está la cosa acá tenemos el allá bueno
el en la dirección de hacia adentro
tenemos ve y el pulgar está apuntando
hacia dónde queda este uno o sea hacia
dónde queda la fuerza de esta forma la
fuerza se está ejerciendo hacia allá
bueno entonces qué sucede ya resumiendo
todo lo que pasa es que tenemos una
fuerza con magnitud de 10 newton y
utilizando la regla de la mano derecha
determinamos que esa fuerza tiene
dirección perpendicular a esta longitud
en esa dirección vale bueno ya se me
acabó el tiempo nos vemos hasta la
próxima